lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
pensar en cómo se forman las expresiones
y las palabras que utilizamos para
describir las diferentes partes de una
expresión y la razón de por qué es esto
útil es cuando escuchas a otras personas
referirse a alguna expresión y decir no
estoy de acuerdo con el segundo término
o el tercer término tiene cuatro
factores o porque es el coeficiente de
ese término 6 sabrás de lo que están
hablando y podrás comunicarte de la
misma manera así que pensemos en lo que
realmente significan esas palabras
tenemos una expresión aquí y la primera
cosa en la que quiero pensar es en los
términos los
términos
de una expresión o el significado de un
término
y una manera de pensar lo es los
términos los términos de una expresión
son aquellos que están sumándose o
sustrayéndose por ejemplo en esta
expresión de aquí tienes tres términos
que se están sumando o sustrayendo el
primero es 2 x 3 se está sumando eso a 4
y luego a eso le está restando 7 y por
lo que en este ejemplo tienes 3 tienes
tres términos el primer término es 2 por
3 el segundo término es solo el número 4
y el tercer término es el número 7 o más
bien es 7 porque ahora pensemos en el
término factor y cuando la gente habla
de un factor sobre todo refiriéndose a
una expresión están hablando de aquellos
que están siendo multiplicados en cada
término
por ejemplo si dices cuáles son los
factores del primer término el primer
término se refiere a este de aquí dos
por tres y hay dos factores hay un 2 y
un 3 se están multiplicando uno con el
otro por lo que aquí tienes dos factores
en el primer término qué pasa con el
segundo término el segundo término de
aquí este fue el primero el segundo
término aquí tiene sólo un factor solo
está el 4 no se está multiplicando con
nada y el tercer término de aquí una vez
más tienes dos factores es el producto
de 7 porque así que tenemos dos factores
aquí tenemos un 7 y un ahí
y este factor constante de aquí este
número 7 que está multiplicando a la
variable también tiene un nombre
especial es llamado el coeficiente de
este término coeficiente
coeficiente y el coeficiente es la
constante que multiplica el resto del
término esa es una manera de pensar en
eso aquí es 7 y podría ser 7x o 7x
receta o 7 x y z cuadrada la constante
que está multiplicando a todos sería
considerada el coeficiente ahora hagamos
unos cuantos ejemplos más en cada uno de
estos te invito ahora mismo a pausar el
vídeo y piensa en cuántos términos hay
cuántos términos hay en cada expresión
cuántos factores hay en cada término y
cuáles son los coeficientes
veamos este primero es claro que tenemos
tres términos que se están sumando este
es el primer término este es el segundo
término y este es el tercer término
entonces este es el primer término este
es el segundo término y este es el
tercer término
y cada uno tiene dos factores este
primero tiene los factores d
y x
el segundo de aquí tiene los factores
x
y sí
y este tercero tiene los factores
ahora cuáles son los coeficientes aquí
recuerda que los coeficientes son
constantes multiplicando un número de
variables por lo que aquí el coeficiente
de este término de aquí es un 3
ahora de seguro estarás preguntándote
cuáles son los coeficientes de aquí y
depende de cómo lo pienses una manera de
verlo es decir hey xy es la misma cosa
que decir uno por xy por lo que algunas
personas dirán que tienes un coeficiente
de uno aquí en el xv o que está ahí
implícitamente no está escrito pero
estás multiplicando todo por uno y eso
podría ser tema de un poco de
interpretación de una manera o de otra
ahora esta es muy interesante porque si
vemos la gran expresión si vemos la
expresión completa si la vemos completa
es claro que está compuesta de tres
términos el primer término es x y z
el segundo término es x
+ 1
todo eso porque y luego el tercer
término
4x
y si ves en ese nivel si ves el primer
término y dices cuántos factores tiene
bueno dirías que tiene tres factores x6
z
cuántos factores tiene el segundo
término bueno podríamos decir que tiene
dos factores un factor es x + 1 y el
otro factor es que si estamos aplicando
x +
el primer factor es x1 y el segundo es
que se están multiplicando en esta
expresión esta expresión entera esta
expresión entera más pequeña es uno de
los factores y el otro eje y luego esta
tercera también tiene dos factores un 4
y una equis y si alguien dijera cuál es
el coeficiente de este término diríamos
mira el coeficiente el coeficiente es
ahora veamos esta de aquí pero de hecho
antes de ver esa volvamos acá rápido lo
que es interesante de esto es que aquí
tienes una expresión más pequeña que por
sí misma está actuando como uno de los
factores así que puedes concentrarte en
esta expresión de aquí y preguntar lo
mismo
cuántos términos tiene esta expresión
más pequeña bueno vemos que tiene dos
términos una xy un 1 esos son los dos
términos que se están sumando
sustrayendo y cada uno de ellos tiene
exactamente un factor así que cuando
trabajamos con esto puedes seguir
anidando estas expresiones para pensar
en cuando analizas términos o factores o
factores de términos
tienes que especificar en qué parte de
la expresión anidada estás pensando
si en los términos de esta expresión
completa hay 1 2 3 o bien puedes mirar
esta sub expresión que completa es el
factor de un término y decir que hay dos
términos en ella ahora veamos esta
cuantos cuantos términos una vez más
claramente son tres no no
de hecho deja añado uno más porque ya
fueron muchas expresiones de tres
términos así que sólo voy a sumarle un
uno aquí
y ahora claramente tenemos cuatro
términos el primer término segundo
término tercer término cuarto término y
cuántos factores hay en cada uno de
ellos bueno esto es interesante podrías
decir bueno los factores son aquellos
que están siendo multiplicados pero aquí
se está dividiendo entre iu y recuerda
que dividir entre y es lo mismo que
multiplicar por su recíproco
así que usualmente se consideraría que
se tienen tres factores aquí los cuales
son 3
x
y uno sobre mí
si multiplicas 3 por equis por 1 sobre
james obtendrás exactamente lo que
tienes aquí
así que dirías que aquí hay tres
factores y si alguien pregunta cuál es
el coeficiente de aquí entonces dirías
que ese 3 es el coeficiente
aquí cuantos factores tienes y esto
puede ser un poco confuso podrías decir
que son 5x cuadrada porque pero no es
eso igual a 5 por x por x porque y
estarías bien y es bastante tentador
decir que tienes 4 factores pero la
convención o lo tradicional que la
mayoría de la gente usa es que ellos
consideran el exponente de con x como
base como sólo un factor esto como solo
un factor por lo que tradicionalmente la
gente diría que esto tiene tres factores
tiene un 5
una equis
cuadrada y una y
x cuadrada es considerada como un factor
y una vez más cuál es el coeficiente
el 5
así que con eso en mente cuantos
factores hay aquí bueno tienes tres
factores aquí tienes una equis
tienes una d cuadrada
y tienes una zeta a la quinta potencia y
finalmente este término es un término
constante cuántos factores tiene tiene
sólo uno hay sólo un uno ahí no se está
multiplicando por nada más